mr. speaker professor Alexis J's report
into child sexual exploitation in
Rotherham between 1997 and 2013 is a
terrible account of an a the appalling
failures by rather on council and by the
police and other agencies to protect
vulnerable children it was a complete
dereliction of duty
it makes for shocking reading 1,400
children on a conservative estimate
sexually exploited raped by multiple
perpetrators trafficked to other towns
and cities abducted beaten intimidated
like the rest of this house I was
appalled to read about these victims and
the horrific experiences to which they
were subjected many also suffered the
injustice of seeing their cries for help
ignored and the perpetrators not yet
brought to justice there can be no
excuse for that
last week I spoke to the Chief Constable
of South Yorkshire Police to receive an
update on the live investigations into
child sexual exploitation in South
Yorkshire and the forces plans to ensure
that victims and witnesses receive the
highest levels of care and support it
would not be appropriate for me to
discuss ongoing investigations in detail
but I can tell the house that there are
currently a number of investigations
covering several hundred victims in
South Yorkshire we must ensure that
these perpetrators are brought to
justice mr. speaker Rotherham is just
the latest in a line of harrowing
revelations about the sexual abuse of
children it is because of cases such as
these that we have hissed are
establishing an independent panel
inquiry to look into the way state and
non-state institutions have treated
child sexual exploitation later this
afternoon I am meeting Professor J to
discuss her report to make sure that her
findings and all the lessons of
Rotherham feed properly into the work of
the panel inquiry